easy Steelers diehard a Pittsburgh
sports diehard through and through and a
great sports fan and you could see it
need sense and in his new film bottom of
the ninth in theaters now is released
last Friday good to see you Joe
Manganiello how are you bud great rich
they should have made the tour sir you
on DP show last week I saw you on Fallon
were you having fun at the expense of
sports broadcasters on Jimmy Fallon a
little bit a little bit yeah I was doing
like kind of a light Harry Caray nice
Harry light which which is like just one
beer in two beers in or something like
that that's right I know the moon is
made of green cheese but if it was would
you ate at them that's cool yeah yeah
you Kenan Thompson and and in Fallon yep
yeah we played mad libs right so he came
up with all these crazy words not
knowing what was going to happen net yes
and then they worked them into a
baseball sports cast were the three of
us where the cash is I mean that sounds
like my job in a very tangential way
very strange you know yes figures you do
like bets ever on shows or people like a
rich 50 bucks work in aluminum siding
somewhere Joe the number of I'm the
number of times I have received texts
from people to say would you say this on
the air right now
I've done it you ever take anybody fr no
I mean I've enough for money or anything
like that as Dan Patrick had me say
grilled cheese for two on the air
because Will Ferrell went on his show
and dared me to be able to do it so I
was on a Thursday night football set I
think it was in Jacksonville it was very
strange that I asked the stage manager
can you please get me a grilled cheese
before the end of the show and I did
that it was the money it was no money it
was just pride I do it for pride you
know I did for pride for money and then
and then it's it's the it's the
forgiveness instead of permission thing
where you know been a
a suit will come up to you afterwards
what was with the grilled cheese thing
and I'm like well I was doing it for
Will Ferrell and Dan Patrick I don't
explain my art that's the answer
Houston at Jacksonville that's it
December 5th 2013 grilled cheese for two
that's coming up on the 6-year
anniversary of something that nobody
thinks is an anniversary let's put it
down we've also done flinch ball on
there you've said a lot of things I've
done that I've done it so Joey what do
you need me to say I got offered a
hundred bucks by the former editor of
People magazine hmm to answer a question
any question on a talk show with sadly
Faye Dunaway let me see if I can ask the
question on the spot right here sadly is
there is there anybody that you whose
Super Bowl window is closing the fastest
let's go to the poll rich you have an
answer
sadly Faye Dunaway weird so you had me
ask that we ask the question yet earlier
on who's Super Bowl window is closing
the fastest right we have quarterback
and it was Roethlisberger and it was
Philip Rivers and it was Drew Brees and
it was Aaron Rodgers and Ben was winning
that poll correct yeah 35 percent in
that poll now you have added I said take
Aaron Rodgers output Brady in right yeah
took Rodgers out put Brady and has that
affected the results at all uh yep okay
wait I got Ben Roethlisberger now 44
percent Tom Brady and Tom Brady in the
last place ten percent okay so Aaron
Rodgers was stealing some of Ben's votes
of no confidence well Beth what do you
think Joe look I mean I don't understand
like is Green Bay were they in a Super
Bowl window I mean were we looking at
them last year as a contender that's
that's my question the other side of it
is like okay I understand like you know
New Orleans made the playoffs like I get
that part of it you know and I get that
okay the Steelers like we didn't last
year we had a very odd year and I
and I think that that's what's
reflecting it but like Philip Rivers in
a Super Bowl window I mean all right
when it's when with San Diego's what
like we actually won Super Bowls and
went to a bunch no I know the Chargers
are definitely in a Super Bowl window
right now I think I I would I would I
would push back on that a little bit
with you but I understand last year
Green Bay when Phil when Aaron Rodgers
hurt his knee and you'd is needed a
Herculean effort just to beat the Bears
who at the time and week one we didn't
think was a playoff team as they turned
out to be and so that we're wondering
what that roster is gonna look like
expecting right here yeah but you know
the drill I mean no no brown no bail no
shot Joe I mean that's really that is
good yes that is we make the playoffs
last year with those guys on roster now
granted one of them didn't show up
because James Connor was running so well
midseason I mean look if you're gonna
come back to her in the bye week and
that's your plan but then your backup
mmm out of his mind and you're gonna
ride the bench is the number two running
back that's not gonna help your market
value so of course you don't come back
to the team I mean I'm just saying like
we didn't make the playoffs with the
distractions and everything going on
last year so you know is that is part of
the as well as you well know that is
part that is a fallacious
I guess storyline is that bail totally
ruined their chances of making it when
he didn't come back because when he
didn't come back they were at an
all-time high when he decided not to
come back and there was no drama they
started losing games
even Joe Hayden just on I mean you know
right that call doesn't happen in New
Orleans it's a different season you know
I mean maybe a B doesn't even leave I
mean it you know what I mean like there
are as a big moment it was a big moment
I mean Connor got hurt to that high
ankle sprain was a total crush and then
within our backup comes in and rushes
for 140 yards I mean you have to give
credit to the Steelers line I mean
there's like some of the best linemen in
the league on that lines
you know you can question your value or
runningbacks value but you know at the
end of the day I think you know as
they've proven you can plug next guy up
into our line and that guy's gonna run
for a buck fifty so what do you think
what are you expecting this season I
like this is underdogs I think everybody
in Pittsburgh likes us as underdogs
whenever they say we're gonna win we
don't and when they when they're not
looking at us that's that's what it
historically happens for us in the
modern Steelers here so you know I'm
fine with all of that I liked the team I
think Pittsburgh loves this team you
know I mean do we wish that players
behaviors would have been different sure
of course we do but it is what it is and
it's not like we didn't know who those
guys were anyway so I like the
distractions gone look man we make the
playoffs it's a better season than last
year and that's the goal right now I
think we got a great team like like
coach Tom like Coach T said we have a
wide receiver who is an all-pro and a
running back who was all-pro last year
so let's not forget about those guys
well they issued Joe Manganiello here
I'm gonna continue playing devil's
advocate that juju wouldn't have had the
season that he had if Antonio Brown
wasn't on the other side drawing double
teams and having the attention of the
defensive coordinator and staff the
entire week long because of who he is
okay you can't you can't argue that
better one two receiver combination
tandem like benefits from each other of
course yeah or that a number two
receiver doesn't benefit from number one
and you know we're gonna see I mean are
you trying to say the juju can't be in
number one I mean I I disagree with that
would disagree with that is fantastic
I would disagree with that yeah so you
can be one and then the question is who
would be the two who are you looking at
the could be the two who could step in
and maybe have the Juju's the juju role
I mean I think I think James Washington
has shown potential and now it's time
for him to step up yep
I think you know we're great at drafting
wide receivers I mean and that's the
thing you know people don't want to give
Ben credit or his windows closing been
led the league in passing last year you
know and if you look at from the start
of Ben's careers whether was Hines Ward
and Plaxico Burress or
we go Burris and Santonio Holmes or you
could just just plug receivers in he's
always he's made receivers into what
they are the reason we could let Mike
Wallace go when he was asking for more
money we're because you know benhams
throwing balls of this young kid named
Antonio
so now Antonio's gone we got ug it's
it's it's gonna be fine it's going to be
fine
to quote Aaron Rodgers or paraphrase
relax you know it's interesting again
that they just we've discussed it off
air and a little bit last time you were
here is that the Steelers have never
really been in the like not since bubby
Brister that nobody believes in us I'm
serious in China I remember vividly
those that was me growing I was born in
the 70s so all you heard about was the
Steelers Championships and then I was
every Sunday I was parking friendly 80
Steelers it was completely different
right but yeah we've been contenders for
a long time which I think speaks to the
strength of the organization and you
look at other organizations that have
trouble pulling out winning seasons like
the one that everyone's talking about
one in the Super Bowl this year in our
division I mean you got to have a
winning season first guy you know that's
what I got to say welcome EJ I'm back
you on this I know it's like all right
I'll believe it when I see it yeah I
mean you can't you can't begrudge Browns
fans for being no no no and that's the
thing is that for the past 20 odd years
it's like people are like oh I'm from
Cleveland I'm sorry I'm like no no no I
don't it's okay like I'm not mad at you
I'm not a tease you would hire a
register you know like we're okay we're
not mad at Cleveland we never happened
but now okay now it's like all right you
want to play all right let's play I
don't know you got the nets you got the
Clippers suddenly they have players you
got the Browns maybe the script Browns
of the Clippers I'm just saying that
maybe they're just flip their scripts
flipping all over the place um you know
you never know okay well congratulations
you won a game last year like Congrats
like here we go let's play I'm excited
for the parade after the week one win
against Tennessee Oh
man you should be quiet cuz this
Steelers teams coming into your house
that on your banner raising night and
can absolutely make your life very much
hey we Pat's loss to the chiefs of spent
a night a couple years we ain't the Pats
the past two years it's not a big deal
how'd that work at the playoffs not a
big deal Steelers won the past two years
in the playoffs against the Pat in the
playoffs
well yeah Jesse James got that ball
remember they changed that rule he's
bringing up and bringing up the fact
that they had you beat but after further
review yeah I mean I'm just saying I
didn't they have changed the rule they
change the rule yeah largely because of
that Joe Manganiello here on the Rich
Eisen show I like it it's saucy it's
bitter it's football season we are here
we have arrived man let's go I know I
can't wait I can't wait let's talk about
your movie let's talk about your movie
baseball film one would say obviously
it's more than just about baseball but
baseball's at the heart of it bottom of
the ninth when you play a kid from the
Bronx who comes out of prison and tries
to get back into baseball and tries to
get back into life in that way through
baseball so well he kind of he gets out
of he gets out of prison so it's a 19
year old kid who grew up in the shadow
of Yankee Stadium and he was an
incredible baseball player and then gets
drafted by the Yankees so the pride of
all the Bronx and he's out one night
with his buddies from the neighborhood
and they get into a fight and he hits
one of the other kids and that kid falls
backward and smacks his head on the curb
and dies and he gets nine years in
prison and then gets time tacked on
basically it's a sentence doubled for
violence in prison which is basically
like just keeping himself alive mm-hmm
and he gets out in his late 30s and
returns to the Bronx and missed his
mother's funeral missed the Yankees just
missed his life and he's just trying to
put his life back together and winds up
getting offered a job by an old minor
league coach to help coach this minor
league team and so he leaves his crummy
job at the fish market and ones up going
and and and gets back into baseball and
in the middle of a pitching duel with a
beardless Brian Wilson I love it the
coaches and players see that he's still
got it and Cashman and
Berni show up and and they they noticed
this old guy who can still hit the ball
and he wants up getting a second shot at
baseball through this minor league team
and then winds up bumping into the girl
whose heart he broke at 19 when he went
into prison that is played by my wife
what's that that what was that like
being in a movie with your wife is the
best yes the best I mean you know we're
both we both been doing this long time
we're pros so it was it was just fun on
that level and then also when you're
away and you shoot on location you miss
your family mr. wife and having her
there you know there's just nothing to
miss and my whole life was right there
so I didn't feel bad about working long
hours and I never felt distracted so
that's great um I am the producer so I
had to make sure that she was in the car
on time that's on me
but I do what all husband's do you just
tell your wife it's half an hour earlier
Oh get in the car you gotta know your
talent you've gotta know your talent as
a producer that's right you have to know
your act you treat your players
differently that's good coaches so let's
talk a little bit more about this gas
here is well Burt young uncle Paulie
from from Rocky yep that was great yeah
here's a little cameo in on the baseball
minor-league team he's like our
equipment guy who's still there yes and
there's a lot of fans of support no
Sopranos who can notice a couple of the
the actors at any past--the or a is
great in the film and Michael Rispoli
also from the deuce yet running on HBO
right now plays the the coach my coach
from years ago was fantastic he's also
he's in billions - he had a little bit
of billions also it was great yes Denis
O'Hare my buddy from True Blood that guy
is two-time Tony was great as they get
yeah he's amazing and um and you know
he's been my friend since True Blood and
and and we stayed close and always
wanted to use him in something that I
was producing you know and he was
gracious enough to lend his talents and
come in and play my parole officer right
he's great my wife of course Brian
Wilson yeah I mean so
huh obviously he hasn't been in baseball
for a few years but I mean what was it
how did you get hooked up with him well
Joe you actually know because you were
there I directed a staged reading of
major-league years ago for the LACMA
series and if you can pull up a picture
maybe on online somewhere oh you have
you have that handy oh that's a poster
ah it's a movie poster of where you did
the live read of major league yeah we so
I directed part of Jason Reitman and
Elvis Mitchell had this LACMA series
where they you know you get to recast
and do a live stage reading write any
screenplay I said I want to do major
league and I had seen Brian Wilson on
there's the alt poster they roll in very
alt poster yep I had seen Brian Wilson
on the George Lopez show okay he didn't
appear as on George Lopez where he was
wearing a pea coat and he looked like I
remember fisherman's friends that get
rid of your cough okay there's like that
little like Hemingway guy with like the
pipe his little seaman's hat there's
Brian Wilson in the middle who played
Ricky Vaughn and he showed up in the
full number 99 Indians Jersey that was
that so that's where you I called him I
said hey man I'm a huge fan of you he
was on George Lopez and he's a genius
like I just was I just spotted I'm like
this guy has it he's brilliant right
this talk show appearance is one of the
most brilliant pieces of comedy I'd ever
seen I'm like I'm gonna put this guy in
something so when we were doing major
league I got his number from Eric
Stonestreet yeah who was like a golfing
buddy of his I found out Stonestreet
knows everybody and I was like your wife
to Brian Wilson yeah and I was like I
need you to come and play Ricky Vaughn
and he was like okay and we started
having these like in-depth acting
conversations like Brian is a trip and
uh and then I said hey man I have this
movie that I'm producing when I get the
financing for it we get up and going I'm
gonna give you a call and I want you to
come and play this adversarial former
siyoung winner who's rehabbing in the
minor leagues that I have this battle
with and he came in and was just amazing
we just he helped me rewrite the ending
like I mean he was such a great resource
kidding yeah he was like I was like
what's the
nor leus picturing pitcher batter battle
that we could have play out and he said
you know what you should do the butcher
boy I was like the butcher boy he's like
yeah it's this old legend about why I'm
not gonna give away the ending I'm not
gonna give all the way but there's a
there's a crazy move called amateur boy
right and and that's alright well since
the one who came up with it yeah he was
like he pitched it to me and he was so
good on the set he's just he's so so
good in this mess awesome yeah that's
great how many takes did it take for
Cashman to get it done right or did he
keep you there all night Cashman and
Bernie are like one take only well
Bernie Bernie had his Seinfeld days I
understand that this is not Bernie's
first rodeo yeah no with Costanza I mean
there was Bernie with Costanza for many
many many Nationals very natural yeah
very natural he was a pro he came in we
were out in like Rockaway at like some
practice field he came all the way out
there on a busy day during the season to
come shoot with us so I was very
grateful for those guys ok never thought
about putting the Pirates in there in
the film that's about the Bronx I got it
I mean it's like it's the Bronx is such
a character in it and guys why we
populated with a bunch of like New York
actors and and you know and I hung out
with with Bronx people and work my my
Bronx dialect dude you are just great
people man you know how I feel you know
how I feel about you at Joe Manganiello
on Twitter and Instagram bottom of the
ninth is in theaters right now with an
incredible cast and I appreciate any
time you make for this show thanks rich
absolutely good also on VOD vis oh yeah
it's in some select like indie theaters
but great if you're at home you want to
watch it right now bottom of the night
outstanding brockmore do you think of
his shoes before we send them oh yeah
these are incredible they are so Guns
and Roses had an album a double album
used your illusions 1 & 2 Joe has custom
Jordan ones I've used your illusions 1 &
2 now those are one of one those are
custom-made just for you right Joe 1
yeah my buddy mosh mosh customs em ACH
if you're on if you're online yeah he
had this great idea he knew I was I was
a rock I a metal guy and that was like
the biggest event musical event of our
generations form
years was usually Lucian's 1 & 2 being
released and he said I'm gonna get
Jordan ones what size are you I'm gonna
do a huge revolution one on one and then
the two on the other he's got a metallic
ain't it he's got the shoes the guns and
roses but he man did you know that
that's what those were the minute he
came out what TJ had showed me a picture
before Joakim as when I saw you in the
green room Michael is a nice colorful
shoes I don't you know thanks to you
fire today rich you got the fire on
right now we go what am i wearing right
now Joe I don't really even know what
I'm wearing but they they make me look
younger despite the move of me putting
this up on the desk I don't know stay
there until you have to run your next 40
oh gosh that'll be five months from now
good to see you Joe great scene you've
got a I'm video on demand and then
theaters near you bottom of the ninth
with Joe Manganiello for more of the
Rich Eisen show tune - audience Channel
239 on DirecTV for free on BR Live or
download the Rich Eisen show app